um in a scene completely Beyond parody
Beyond satire and also a horrifying
scene I mean it's both a group of white
supremacists staged a bizarre rally in
Washington DC over the weekend they wore
masks as part of their outfits or maybe
we maybe were supposed to call them
uniforms I don't know outfits is a
little bit emasculating
um and thanks to some kind of issue with
U-Haul rental trucks if you can believe
it some of them ended up being like
stranded in Washington DC for hours just
based on poor planning now of course for
me the real story here is once again
look at how this group of protesters is
treated by law enforcement and others
compared to so many others at protests
around the country but we're going to
get to that in a moment uh the story is
that about a hundred members of what is
now called The Patriot front if that
name doesn't ring a bell I'll explain
that as well in a moment a hundred
members of the Patriot front group
rallied in Washington DC near the White
House over the weekend now Patriot front
used to be known as Vanguard America but
they changed their name why did they
change their name well because someone
affiliated with Vanguard America
murdered a woman in that Infamous unite
the right rally in Charlottesville
Virginia so Vanguard America was tainted
now they are Patriot front okay they
were there chanting that they are trying
to reclaim America according to our
friend Zach patrizo from The Daily Beast
their uh outfits or uniforms consisted
of white Gators or masks
sunglasses Blue Jackets khaki pants
brown boots hats shin guards and masks
they also had American flags plastic
Shields that looked really like toys if
you look at the pictures and snare drums
as well now how did police react well
police shadowed the group
apparently to prevent conflicts from
starting and there are some who were
upset that the police seemed to in this
case be protecting the protesters
whereas in left-leaning protests they
the claim is are more antagonistic to
the protesters and are instead
protecting counter protesters now I
think the reality is more complicated
than that uh
and there is much more that could be
said about that
um but the funniest part was the
completely abortive climax to this thing
where dozens of them got stranded there
were there were only a hundred dozens
ended up stranded because they rented
U-Haul trucks to get themselves to the
rally and one of the big trucks couldn't
fit all of them so they waited for hours
as the truck made multiple trips I
genuinely have been unable to find
answers to some basic questions about
this rally did they have a permit as
many of you know
one of the uh it's it's sort of like the
equivalent of resisting arrest for
rallies you know we've talked before how
when police decide
they want to make trouble for a
particular individual or a particular
group this very vague charge of
resisting arrest enters the picture and
it's ripe for abuse along the same lines
when it comes to rallies or protests
whose subject matter some don't like it
becomes well did they have a permit for
the rally I don't know the answer
whether they did or did not why were
they allowed because remember police
were shadowing them as they were
stranded because of the U-Haul truck
issue and the truck was going back and
forth stuffed with these guys
why were they allowed to bring masses of
people around in U-Hauls which have no
seat belts for each person in the back
no padding it's against the law to do
that as well part of the story of why
was this the treatment that these
individuals received rather than fill in
the blanks with whatever example you
want from protests over the last year
and a half sort of starting with
starting with the George Floyd protests
in the summer of 2020. let me know your
thoughts you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman and remember that we've got on
December 14th at 6 PM eastern time we
will be doing the next David packman
show viewer Town Hall it'll be streaming
live on the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel
that's the second Channel not the one
that these clips are on it's on the
second Channel and it'll be uh next next
uh what is it Tuesday
yeah next Tuesday Tuesday December 14th
6 p.m Eastern on the Pacman live Channel